You ever shot any guns before?
- Huh-uh.
- Why not?
To get that wood I
need, we've got to go
to the gator nesting spot.
I call it Alligator Alley.
It's a dangerous
place, [inaudible]..
NARRATOR: Now, the Swamp
Man knows a thing or two
about gators, and
he's tangled with them
on more than a few occasions.
- Watch him, Shel!
- Ah!
Gators know when their
damn food's ready.
They can smell it.
I just want them to know that
the food is the fish, not me.
Ow!
Put one in it.
NARRATOR: So he's going to
teach his young protege, Angela,
how to provide some
added protection
for when they go down river.
Don't never point
a gun at nobody,
and don't never walk
around with his safety off.
[gunshot]
I barely know
anything about guns,
and Shelby was basically
born with one in his hand.
[gunshot]
Boy, that's a good one, Pawpaw.
You ready to shoot
some targets, man?
Yeah!
Shelby's like a gun master,
so it's kind of intimidating.
I just hope I can measure
up to his standards.
We're going to try
this one right here.
Looky here.
.44 magnum.
This is my daddy's gun.
Get up on that log, so
you have the height.
Let's see how she does.
Is she Annie Oakley,
or is she just Annie?
I have to cock it first.
Good thing we
wasn't in the war.
We'd have been dead
a long time ago.
[gunshot]
Got it?
Dang, that's got a kick on it.
Shoot it!
[gunshot]
Got to shoot it
from the hip, baby.
There ain't no
sights on that gun.
[gunshot]
[bleep]
Oh my god.
NARRATOR: Angela
with a pistol has
proven to be about as useful
as a steering wheel on a mule.
Too close.
[inaudible]
Did you get it?
No, I hit-- do you see
that big hole in front of me?
That's what I hit.
This is humiliating, and
kind of embarrassing.
[gunshot]
You're definitely missing it.
I'm not very good at it.
That girl couldn't hit
the side of a damn barn door
with a cannon.
Let me show you this
other gun right here.
This is the gun my
grandpa's daddy gave me
when I was a little bitty
child, children child,
when I couldn't even walk.
I was just crawling, and still
sucking on a cow's titty.
NARRATOR: But nobody thought
following in the Swamp
Man's footsteps would be easy.
It's a 12 gauge.
[gunshot]
NARRATOR: So Shelby is
bringing out a rifle that might
be a tad easier to steady.
Here, shoot it one time.
Ready?
Yeah.
Put the safety in.
And hold it tight
to your shoulder.
Put it on your shoulder now.
Go ahead.
[gunshot]
- [bleep]
[laughing]
[gunshot]
Woo!
You are getting better.
[inaudible]
Now this one here, this
is a Rossi .44 magnum.
Always on safety.
- OK.
There you go.
See if [inaudible]
tell you-- teach you.
[gunshot]
[bleep] She's
doing good, Junior.
[inaudible] And
let them have it.
[gunshot]
Woo!
NARRATOR: Now this
young logger may
not be the next Dirty Harry--
[gunshots]
--but thanks to the
Swamp Man, she's
got one more skill
under her belt,
and she's ready for
Alligator Alley.
We've got to get in the
water and swim with the gators.
Here we go.
Give me the bullets.
That's how it's done.